yes sir yes sir I got back on the phone
we just reaching back out to you
brother
said I appreciate that I appreciate that
mean a lot to me you know yeah no like
the prophet wasam said you know you
know the brother the believer to the
believer like a building one part
you know the other you know one one part
of the body aches the other the you know
the other you know the other body parts
complain complains with fever and sleep
brother you know you know the situation
means a lot to us yes thank
you yeah but U I'm you know I'm I'm um
um very
reflective
um I'm leaning with the
hope no that Allah have mercy n
[Music]
um
alhamdulillah
it's constantly focusing
on
being in a situation where Allah send
the Angels down and to give you that
Titans of that good pleasure of Allah
and dig
yeah you
know it's like you
know a
[Music]
struggle but not so much as a struggle
but the focus constantly
focusing on that which
is pleasing to Allah
sallam brother
khif yes you know Allah said in theith
Inari I am as my servant thinks about me
I'm with him when he remembers me if he
remembers me within himself I remember
him and if he remembers me in a
gathering I remember him in a gathering
that's greater and better than it so at
the end of the day just have good
thoughts about
Allah you know ald
you know prepare for that you know with
repentance and seeking forgiveness but
have good thoughts about him because and
also know that
Justice will be established you know
regardless you know on that day before
Allah all quarrels and disputes will be
settled and as Allah said in the
Quran never think Allah is heedless of
what the oppresses they do people have
different tests and trials and Allah
tests us on the account of the strength
of our religion and it's something that
we can deal with and something that we
can get past by the will of Allah and I
think that you know alhamdulillah your
strength You Know M and your resolve
mallah is you know commendable may Allah
bless you I
told I think it would be nice you know
do you have any advice like for the
Muslims that we could share with them
you know no doubt we believe in the
Hereafter and may Allah gather us all in
Paradise with the prophets The
Messengers The Companions and the
righteous but in before you you know
before we leave you any any advice that
you would like to share with the Muslims
your brothers and sisters
globally yes just two short quick things
that I was thinking about and um one of
them is suggest
to strive to be a true slave servant of
Allah and focus upon the you know what
I'm saying of Allah as the prophet s
wasam he gave example and he chose to be
a prophet slave and we try to emulate
that as you know saying being regular
Believers know saying but we striving
for that humility you know what I'm
saying to be a servant a true servant of
Allah subhana and every AER and uh the
other thing is based
upon the ayat very short Ayah from
U
um ay
13 when you know what Allah L talks
about
Bly
um I got it it's
uh verely those who say our Lord is only
Allah and there after stand firm on them
should be no fur nor should they grieve
so I've been thinking about that all day
and sharing it with other brothers and
sisters you know what I'm saying and
that's been really you know I'm saying
giving me Comfort you know what I'm
saying so yeah so in every situation
alhamdulillah like the prophet wasallam
used to say when faced with a situation
that he necessarily didn't like he still
said
alhamdulillah so that's what I say and
share with the brothers and sister
may Allah subh waala make easy what is
best for you in the and the and may
Allah allow us to meet in the
or the most important thing that he's
pleased with us and we die upon
the that's the most important thing you
know it doesn't matter how long a Liv
you know the most important thing is the
way that they end and alhamdulillah you
know I know that you know your situation
is not easy but you you look at the
positive alhamdulillah you have the
opportunity to prepare to prepare right
and to rectify what is you know between
you and Allah and that opportunity
sometimes not afforded to other people
other some some people you know they
they they die in the Disobedience or you
know disbelief and ending is immediate
and they didn't have any you know chance
to rectify that so I I know like I said
it's a it's a difficult circumstance but
alhamdulillah I'm sure you know your
understanding of the religion and
studying over the years alhamdulillah
the Quran and the Sunnah with the
understanding of the companions you know
prepared you for any moment or
whatever's decree for you and
alhamdulillah you like you said
alhamdulillah we submit to the decree of
Allah we accept it and the highest level
is that we're pleased with it and you
reach that level like I said earlier
like the prophet sallallahu alai
wasallam said in Allah said in
theith I am as my servant thinks about
me have a good thought about Allah Allah
he loves the Believers he loves those
who strive to be righteous and he's the
most merciful he's the most
compassionate the all forgiving so my
brother I didn't get a chance to meet
you in this D but I love you for the
sake of Allah and I ask Allah
Allah what your gather us in a gathering
that's pleasing whatever Allah
determines you know I'm saying I'm
satisfied with it whatever you know so I
already been right there at that at that
moment and I you know what I'm saying
there's nothing changed about it you
know I'm still like I said before I
don't believe in the system the criminal
justice system I don't believe in it you
know what I'm saying to that degree but
I know that it can be used for good as
well so if good come out for me and for
my family and for all those that been
supporting me and all praise be to Allah
there's a a little supplication that the
prophet Muhammad peace and blessing be
upon him he used to say he used to say
oh Allah if life is good for me then
give me life if death is good for me
then give me death you know what I'm
saying so that's how I feel you know I'm
saying I say the same supplication so
yeah I'm at peace of course